And today, I'm going to talk
about external tools in Canvas.
Since we started
using Canvas, we've
been experimenting with
a lot of external tools.
And external tools
are the tools that
are available through Canvas.
So it could be any other tool,
or developed by our developers
at the school, that we
access them through Canvas.
So most of these integration
are available through the course
navigation.
And I'm going to
show some examples.
Some of the integrations
that, when you access to them,
they are on the
left navigation bar,
so you can access through that.
Some of them are available
through assignments.
So if you're using a
specific tool, external tool,
you can only access them
through assignments.
And some of the
examples are here,
like MobLab and Critiquett.
Some of them are
available through modules.
So in order to use those
tools, you have to use modules.
And also, HTML editor that we
are using right now, Warpwire.
And I'm going to show that.
And we also experimented
by integrating these tools
within the sub account
and within courses.
So we tried different levels
of integrations, also.
So past and current--
so far, we use Warpwire.
We name it.
It shows on the
left navigation bar,
and we name it Course Videos.
Warpwire is our media platform.
So instead of Panopto, School
of Management is using Warpwire.
And this is how we are accessing
Warpwire from within Canvas.
So basically, I'm
just going to, maybe--
so you can see it here.
It's on the left navigation.
And then, students, or
users and instructors,
when they click on
it, they are accessing
Warpwire within Canvas.
And it's already integrated.
They don't have to go to another
platform to use the platform,
they just, within Canvas,
access to this platform.
So I'll go to the next one.
SOM Syllabus,
that's another tool
that they will opt at
the School of Management
to have access to our syllabi
on a different platform.
So I'm going to
show an example too.
And hopefully, we will be
retiring that tool soon,
because we are going to
go back to the syllabus
available within Canvas.
So if a user clicks
on the SOM Syllabus,
they have access to
the syllabus that
is actually hosted in another
platform, called Confluence.
So again, without
leaving Canvas,
by clicking on that
link, they access to it.
And they don't have to sign in.
They don't have to enter
any user name or password.
Roster-- Roster too was
developed by S1 developers
also.
We since then retired it,
because now, the university
has a really good photo
roster that we can use.
But before university
had a roster,
we created our own
with the pictures,
and with the name of the
students and their emails.
We are not using it any
more, but that's another tool
that we developed and
we've been using in Canvas.
And VoiceThread-- again,
while integrating Canvas,
we integrated a lot of tools.
And one of the tools that we
tried out was VoiceThread.
And VoiceThread is an online
platform for providing feedback
on the media files.
And the feedback can be an
audio file, video file, text,
and any type of file
that you can share.
So I'm going to click on it,
so you see how we access it.
But since then, we stopped
paying for the VoiceThread
license, so we don't
have any access to it.
But again, VoiceThread
was available
on the left navigation bar,
as well as in Assignments.
So we could create
assignments and have
students access VoiceThread.
Or we were using it on
the left navigation bar,
so our users would just click
on it, and go to VoiceThread,
without entering their
username and password.
So these are the ones
that we've been using.
And these are tested.
So when I say tested, I mean,
we hear about these tools,
and we read about them, and we
investigate, and we implement
it, sometimes, at
[INAUDIBLE] level,
sometimes, at the
sandbox, at course level.
I try to do it mostly
at the course level.
These are some of the
ones that we tested.
And we decided that
it's not ready yet.
It's not working as much as
we want them to be working.
There are some issues with them.
So we are still either
trying to decide,
or decided not to pursue.
So one of them is
called Turnitin.
You're all familiar
with Turnitin.
It's a plagiarism tool.
And we are using it externally.
So our faculty and staff
members are going to Turnitin
and uploading all
these documents.
So we were thinking
it would be helpful
if you provide this
access within Canvas.
Unfortunately,
right now, you see
error, because my test
account is expired.
We had some issues with it.
It wasn't 100% accurate.
It works better externally,
as another platform,
rather than within Canvas.
So we are still trying to
decide if we should just
ask our users to use an external
platform, or use within Canvas.
The next one that
we are testing is--
actually, we did already.
We are not pursuing it,
because library just
made a presentation, so we
are one of the schools using
Ares system heavily.
So if you were to use Harvard
Business Publishing LTI, that
would mean our students
would go to course files,
and then toward course reserves,
and then Harvard cases.
So they would have to go
to three different places
to get one course material.
So we decided that,
unless it integrates
with course resources
or files, we are not
going to use Harvard cases.
So we decided not to.
I don't have any
access to it right now.
Study.Net-- just another one.
I don't know if you're
familiar with Study.Net.
Study.net allows faculty
members, instructors,
to create their course packs.
It could be a web
site, it could be
a file of their
own creation, or it
could be a case that is
developed and presented
by any other business school.
So we also tested it.
And we decided that
we are not going
to go with it, because just like
with Harvard Business cases,
this required our
students and faculty
to go to yet another place.
Here, right now,
currently, they only
go to files and course
reserves, which is down there.
But if they were
to use Study.Net,
then they would also
have to go to Study.Net
to get some of the files.
So we are looking
for a solution that
will allow us to put all the
resources in one place, so
our students and
faculty, they don't
have to go to three or
four different places.
We haven't found it
yet, but we are looking
and continue to look.
So currently being tested--
so our last two tools
that are currently
being tested and piloted--
one of them is CritiqueIt.
It was introduced by CTL.
So after investigating
it, I introduced it
to one of our faculty members.
He has used it for
his spring class.
And he actually--
for CritiqueIt,
as I mentioned
before, some tools
are available
within assignments.
So CritiqueIt is available
only through Assignments.
So if you decide
to use a tools that
allows faculty instructors
to use this tool,
so we have to use CritiqueIt
through Assignments.
So when they create
an assignment,
and they select External
Tool, and students
if they need to use it, they
go through the Assignments.
And CritiqueIt is an
online critiquing tool
that allows instructors to--
or users, I should say,
because students can also
upload files--
they can upload their images or
their videos, or even like Word
files, and people can
give comments on them.
They can record videos, and they
can provide comments on them.
I'm going really fast,
but you can ask me more,
because we have a
couple of minutes left.
So currently, we are
also testing VeriCite.
I mentioned our
issues with Turnitin,
so we are investigating another
online plagiarism tool called
VeriCite and trying to see if
it works better within Canvas.
So we are currently testing it.
So we've been doing some tests.
And if we decide,
OK, this is better,
then I'm going to
ask a faculty member
to pilot it for next fall.
And then, we will be able
to decide after the pilot
if we're going to go
with the tool or not.
So again, it's via Assignments.
I select External
Tool, select VeriCite.
So students when they're
uploading their files,
assignment files,
they go within Canvas,
but they're actually
uploading in VeriCite.
And faculty can access,
also, from Canvas.
Finally, coming soon-- so this
is the tool that we tested
and we piloted.
We didn't pilot within Canvas,
but we piloted outside.
And we decided to go with it.
It's called MobLab.
It's an online gaming for
economics and business cases.
So we are going to start
using it next fall.
And just like I
mentioned before,
MobLab is available through
Assignments or Modules.
So a person who
presented about modules--
so we can put MobLab games and
activities under each module.
It allows us to do that.
So as you can see,
first, we activate it.
So that's one thing.
Some of the external
tools require activation.
So we require students
to click there first,
to activate their account.
And then they access
through SOM icon.
And now, their account
is activated in MobLab.
They can start using it.
So we can start weekly modules
and add MobLab games for them
to access it.
And thank you.
Any questions?
Yes?
So are these platforms
that you've developed?
Some of them.
Like the syllabus,
that, we developed.
And roster, we developed.
But MobLab, VeriCite,
Turnitin, it's
developed by the companies.
So I need to have a sign up
tool for my students for labs.
And the scheduler
in Canvas doesn't
work for what I need to do.
So I'm learning how to do it
in a data-based platform called
Airtable.
And it has an API, but the
students don't have access to--
I don't have access to the
roster and their schedule
and so forth.
So they have to get an
account on a separate platform
and so forth.
So it would be great if I could
get the roster information
and so forth or the Airtable
tool into the Canvas API.
So can I do that?
[LAUGHTER]
You need to contact Pilar
and her team, I think.
We worked with them to
create our own tools for SOM,
but you have to check with them.
So all the databases that
we use for the roster
came from S1 databases.
Yeah.
So it sounds like it
worked for you then.
It worked, yes.
And there's also
some Canvas groups
that they do share their
resources and developments
on GitHub.
So you may find something
like that already developed,
and you just modify it
to your own purposes.
I'd say the roster was tricky,
because our developers were
pulling information that always
was inaccurate to Banner.
So in the People
tool, and then I
know that the Roster
tool that we use now,
it was calling
different students.
Yeah.
So It's tricky, but I
think it's all sorted out.
Yeah.
OK.
One other comment.
There's a web
site, EduAppCenter,
that lists over 200
externally developed tools
for various things
that are already
plug-and-play for Canvas.
That's not to say that you can
just immediately plug it in.
We have some protocols
for actually checking
to make sure that any data
shared with an external vendor
is secure, because of FERPA
and that sort of thing.
But you might very well
find an application
that does what you're looking
for on the EduAppCenter.
And then you can contact the
Canvas group and say, hey,
I would really like to look into
plugging this into my setup.
Yeah.
Any questions?